for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
so in the last video we mentioned the
quantum numbers what was going on with
them and we specifically mentioned that
the angular momentum quantum number l
relates to the shape of the atomic
orbital ok so we also mentioned
specifically that the values of L had a
corresponding letter in each of those
letters corresponds to a certain shape
so that's we're going to go over here so
there's an S orbital p orbital D orbital
and F orbital so let's start off with
the S orbital the S orbital its shape is
spherical ok and that's actually shown
over here we'll get to that in just a
second so L value is equal to 0 and it's
spherical the probability density is
highest near the nucleus because it is a
sphere ok where the sphere center is in
is the nucleus so the possible M sub L
value is if we think about the L value
is just 0 which means that there's only
one orientation in space and that makes
sense if you think about holding a
sphere in your hand is there any way
that you can kind of flip it or hold it
in a different position that makes it
look like anything different than what
it is it's going to look like us the
same sort of sphere oriented in the same
way no matter how you kind of turn it
around ok so there's only one
orientation in space for a sphere or the
S orbital ok so here I've drawn the
basically three s orbitals for the N
equals 1 N equals 2 and N equals 3 so
the N equals 1 we see here is this
is represented here by this little red
dot that's just in 2d so we can see that
basically the red portion is the area of
high probability okay so this is
specifically the 1s orbital okay so this
is a 2d representation down here is the
3d representation and this white outline
doesn't mean anything specific the
outline itself is just was just a way
for me to sort of depict the shape so
don't think about the white outline
meaning anything in specific this is
just like if you took a fear like this
and you cut a little wedge like a like
an orange slice or an orange wedge from
the fruit it would look kind of like
this right if you cut a fourth of a
fourth of a an orange right into a
little wedge like this would look like
this ok now this over here is the 2's
orbital in this over here is the 3s now
there's this you'll notice that there's
a space in between the two areas of high
probability right the two areas of high
permeability are generated in red and
the space in between them is an area of
actually zero probability this space in
here is a node this is a node right and
in the second depiction that's shown
here let's do it let's do in a blue it's
colored in in white that area there is a
node and that's an area where the
probability density actually equals zero
so the probability density at the note
equals zero which means that the
electron cannot be located there at all
that's kind of weird and we'll get to
why that's weird in just a second so
what support for the 1s orbital there
are no nodes or the 2's orbital there's
one node and for the 3s orbital there
are two notes there are two regions of
zero probability and we can see that you
guys a node here right and there's a
note here those are both notes and in
this here
that's a node there and a node there
those are nodes so the number of nose is
just n minus 1 okay now at the node we
said the electron cannot be there so if
the above statement is true how is it
that an electron can pass from one area
of high probability to another how can
that be if we take an electron let's
imagine electron right here in this
loops that's kind of big let's try like
in its right here really close to the
nucleus and it needs to go here how can
it go there without passing through that
note all right or how can how can it go
from here into here or from here to here
how can it do that right doesn't have to
pass through that space is there's no
way that it can't pass through that note
so how is it that these nodes have zero
probability well think about it this way
is taking into account electron and
electrons particle nature but instead we
think about electron electrons wave
nature electrons wave nature explains
how that can happen right it's it's not
you can't imagine it as a particle going
from one point to the next you didn't
imagine it as a wave being being in a
certain region and propagating in
another region so it's kind of weird
okay one last thing I wanted to mention
is that as we go from N equals 1 to N
equals 2 in an equals 3 we can see that
the electron can be further and further
away from the nucleus right so again
that just is is the idea that if an
electron is further away from the
nucleus it is higher in energy because
it doesn't want to be further away from
the nucleus it wants to be closer to
that positive charge in the nucleus so
that's the S orbital next up is the p
orbital and that's where the L value
equals 1 and the shape of a p orbital is
like a dumbbell or a bowtie so I've kind
of drawn both here dumbbell like people
use those to lift weights and a bow tie
is kind of drawn like this so a
p-orbital kind of looks like this and
we'll see how that looks in just a
second
it's but it's l value is one right so
this that's only possible if the n value
is equal to or greater than two right
there's no one p orbital that's not
possible because that would mean n
equals one and you can't have L equal to
1 if n equals 1 right so the only
possible p orbitals are 2 p 3 p 4 p and
so on okay you cannot have a 1 p orbital
so the p orbital basically has two lobes
that are on either side of the nucleus
and each of those have high probability
densities okay the nucleus itself is
along the nodal plane so we don't have
just a region that is a note in the way
that we have with the S orbital we have
a plane that the electron cannot sort of
lie on and now kind of represent that
here so the possible M sub L values of
the p orbital are negative L to L right
so that would be negative 1 0 and
positive 1 which means that there are
three possible orientations in 3d space
for the p orbital okay so we have to
think about the x y&z axes okay so we
can think about the p orbital line on
the X on the x axis on the y axis or on
the z axis so that's what we'll see here
so these aren't perfect representations
here but the idea is that there's two
regions of high probability on either
side of the nucleus okay so the electron
can be in either of these lobes so this
one's on the PX this from the low py and
PZ so so they're on the different axes
in 3d space so in the case of the of the
the X orbital the the plane the court
the plane that the y and z axes make is
the nodal plane which means that that's
the plane where the electron cannot be
located and in the case of the why it's
the x and z axes that make up the nodal
plane and then the case of the Z of the
PZ orbital where it's a lot along the z
axis
the XY plane is the nodal plane so
that's kind of represented like this all
right so this this this plane that the y
and z axes make is a nodal plane for the
PX orbital the py orbital is like this
its orientation is different right and
the nodal plane is the x z axis and then
the Z the PZ orbital has the nodal plane
as the XY plane so along that nodal
plane the electron cannot lie oh cool
all right so next up is the D orbital so
hide that for a second let's see what's
going on with the D orbitals the shape
of the D orbitals there clover shaped ok
we have like four leaf clovers now
you'll see a little asterisk next to
that and that's because there's one
weird one that's not quite a little
clover shape so the D orbitals l value
is is 2 and this is only possible if the
n value is greater than or equal to 3
there is no one D orbital and there's no
2 D orbital there's only 3 d 4 D 5 D so
on and so forth so this is clover shape
so it's got four lobes and there's
actually two nodal planes whereas the p
orbital had 11 nodal plane the deal bruh
has two nodal planes it was really
really tough for me to kind of represent
this in 3d at really encourage you to do
like an image search on Google to find
out what's going on with these with
these I try to wrap my best to represent
it but it's not perfect so I definitely
encourage you to to google this the
possible M sub L values here are going
to be negative a little positive a also
negative 2 negative 1 0 positive 1 and
positive 2 so that's five possible
orientations in space so that's what's
shown here there's going to be there's
going to be a DXY orbital a DX z and a
DX or dy z orbital and there's going to
be a DX x squared will do y squared
orbital and addy
z squared over all so those are the five
different orientations and there you
look kind of like this okay little
clover shapes now my representations are
not perfect they're nowhere near perfect
but they just kind of give you an idea
of how these things are shaped and there
are two nodal planes which I did not
show because it got really really messy
but the point is that there are four of
them that have this sort of clover shape
there's this one this one this one and
this one this one here is the exception
it's the weird one okay it looks kind of
like a p-orbital that's surrounded by a
donut I mean that's not really a
scientific way to look at it but that's
kind of what it looks like the point is
that it's the exception to the overall
shapes but that's sort of a
representation of what's going on with
these guys for Lopes the f orbital up
next it's L value is 3 and its shape is
all kinds of complicated the possibility
for bottles are crazy I don't even
really know what it look like I've seen
one but it's at the point is that it's
crazy it's only possible if the n value
is greater than or equal to 4 so there
are no there are no 1 F 2 F or 3 F
orbitals there's only four f5f and so
forth the shapes of the F orbitals are
like I said all kinds of complicated
they are multi lobed they are multi
lobed and gnarly the possible M sub L
values are negative 3 to positive 3 so
negative 3 negative 2 negative 1 0
positive 1 positive to positive 3 so
there are seven F orbitals which means
there are seven possible orientations in
3d space so I did not show a depiction
here because the D orbitals were
complicated enough and I kind of mess
mess them up they're not pretty and I
really did not I had no chance of
depicting an F orbital properly I'd
encourage you to google image search
though for better representations of
what's going on there but I hope that
video was helpful in providing you some
insight as to what is going on with the
shapes of these
orbital's w it was helpful thank you for
watching if you found that video helpful
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
and share with friends thank you and
happy studying